there should be no such thing as student
debt this far right corrupt Supreme Court
and with this unjust decision
is it unjust to make people pay
back court just struck there's no binds loan for
getting his plan ruling 6-3 that the plan was an
unconstitutional overreach of executive spending
power and man was Biden trying to spend the truth
is canceling student debt would be expensive but
counterproductive and do absolutely nothing to
reduce the cost of going to college by some
estimates the plan would have cost over 400
billion dollars most of which would have gone
to helping wealthy Americans without actually
decreasing student debt in the long term the
plan also screws over those who made sacrifices
to pay off their debt or avoid it all together
as well as a generation of students about to
enter College who won't see the benefits of
debt forgiveness instead we should focus on
policies that attack the root of the issue
doing anything else is the real unjustice